c'est un périmètre bien visibles au sol
en rappel visuel pour la sécurité des
employés de ce manufacturier de boîtes
de camions en fibre de verre
depuis le début du confinement on roule
au minimum chez fibre au bec à beloeil
juste assez pour servir les clients des
services essentiels à partir de lundi
avec la reprise graduelle des activités
manufacturières partout au québec
une grande partie des travailleurs
devraient revenir à l' usine mais en
période de pandémie
les retrouvailles seront étroitement
réglementé ça fait des années 30 a qui
travaillent ensemble ces gens là donc
sont habitués naturellement de se
rapprocher dans leurs nouvelles routines
tous les employés de fibres bec devront
entrer par une seule et unique porte ils
devront se laver les mains souvent ils
ne pourront plus boire aux fontaines et
devront suivre des repères au sol pour
se rendre aux toilettes ou encore à la
cafétéria
selon entente entre l'employé et
l'employeur pour dire que yoko symptômes
augmentation de la paperasse également
avec un document à signer chaque fois
que l'on revient à l usine
après les jours de repos un employé qui
décide enfin de salerne l'air de bouger
d'une région à un autre de faire un
aparté avec 50 personnes qui revient ici
leur dit qu'ils dispo en aucune façon
dont
on n'est pas dans l'intrusion de la vie
privée des gens loin de là on essaye de
gérer notre usine mon mieux comme on
peut le lire dans nos moeurs nos
capacités est ce que ces mesures vont
trop loin et menaces tels les droits des
travailleurs
certains sont préoccupés et beaucoup
d'implication légal quand on regarde
l'employé ce niveau là mais je voudrais
qu'il y beaucoup de questions on a fait
beaucoup de webinaires avec des avocats
spécialisés en droit du travail pour
voir quelles questions l'employeur peut
poser aux travailleurs par rapport à son
état de santé sa température
ses autres activités donc c'est très
préoccupant
c'est délicat aussi la bonne nouvelle
chez fribourg bex et que le carnet de
commandes est plein et puis ici les
employés sont tissés serrés et ont le
sentiment d'appartenir à une grande
famille
il devrait revenir en grand nombre au
travail car là ce sera aussi le grand
retour de main sur tous les chantiers
construction du québec
oui il faut se rappeler qu'il ya déjà un
secteur de la construction qui a repris
celui de la construction résidentielle
qui a recommencé le 20 avril
et maintenant ce sont tous les autres
grands chantiers on pense par exemple
aux infrastructures par exemple où nous
sommes en ce moment celui du rem dans la
grande région métropolitaine qui devrait
pouvoir réaccueillir donc des
travailleurs à partir de demain il faut
aussi penser aux chantiers sur les
routes
il ya la réfection de l'autoroute 20 par
exemple à la hauteur de vaudreuil dorion
il ya toute une liste qui existe déjà
il ya bien sûr d'autres projets qui vont
s ajouter à cela comme pour la
construction résidentielle va falloir
suivre les règles de la santé publique
distanciation physique lavage des mains
il ya beaucoup de travail des équipes
comme dans la construction résidentielle
donc quand ça sera pas possible de
garder le 2 m il va falloir donc porter
des équipements de protection
individuelle il reste à voir si tout le
monde doit répondre à l'appel parce
qu'il reste d'autres secteurs d'activité
qui n'ont pas repris comme par exemple
l'ouverture des écoles faudra voir aussi
si les travailleurs n'ont pas peur de
revenir au travail
alors ça sera donc à surveiller dans les
prochains jours merci carla